everyone loves a hero story it's
satisfying to see good overcome evil and
then ride off blissfully into the sunset
but there's a long history of stories
with Heroes who don't get their happily
ever after According to Aristotle the
function of these so-called tragic
Heroes was to provide a catharsis or a
release of emotions for the audience
when a fatal character flaw led to the
hero's untimely demise the tragic hero
is meant to be the face of a cautionary
Tale But Irish folklore offers an
interesting take on this classic
archetype in the story of cocoon A
Gifted Warrior who knew from childhood
that he would live a short but legendary
life
cucullen is considered by many to be the
greatest hero in Irish mythology with
only one real rival for the top spot the
hunter Finn McCool most of our knowledge
of these and other figures from Celtic
folklore come from records taken by
Christian monks in the 11th and 12th
centuries before that the people we now
call the Celts thanks to ancient Greeks
were an oral Society they passed
Knowledge from one generation to the
next in the form of stories poems or
songs that were recited and memorized
the Celts were a collection of
culturally similar but independent
tribes who traveled from the Alps around
1200 BCE and spread across much of
Western Europe by the 3rd Century BCE
Rome conquered much of Europe two
centuries later but the Northern parts
that became Ireland Scotland and Wales
remained mostly unbothered for another
several hundred years the Monk's records
don't reveal too much about Celtic
societies and it's impossible to say how
their Christian Perspective influenced
the writing we do have but we know that
the Celts understood astronomy respected
nature and valued cattle so highly that
wars were often fought as cattle raids
or one-on-one duels between Champions
remember that because it will come up
later modern Scholars have divided the
stories from these records into four
roughly chronological Cycles mythology
Ulster Fenian and historical each cycle
is full of really interesting stories
and if you want to learn about some of
the mythology cycle check out the
monstrum episode on Celtic fairies
but here we'll focus on the Ulster cycle
which is set around the time of Christ
and heavily features the life of the
Warrior kukalan born with the name
Satanta anyone could tell kukalan was
destined to be a hero from the beginning
simply because his birth was so
remarkable kakullen's mother was a woman
named dectana the sister of konkobar
mechanessa King of Ulster or olid the
region of Northern Ireland for which the
folkloric cycle is named satanta's
father was the sun god look one of the
mythical tuaha de Denon there are
multiple versions of satanta's birth
story in one daktina and her handmaidens
are whisked away on the eve of her
wedding to the mystical Otherworld where
she accidentally drinks a tiny version
of look and becomes pregnant in another
coca Colin is conceived Thrice at first
he was born to a woman who daktina
helped through Labor thanks to look's
interference but he died in childhood as
dectana's Foster son next he was
conceived in a dream decked in a hat of
the sun god look but she aborted the
pregnancy because she was married to a
mortal man finally became pregnant by
her husband and was urged by look to
name the baby boy Satanta
when Satanta was a young boy around six
in most versions of the tale he earned
himself a new name he traveled with his
family to the home of the blacksmith
Cullen for a feast where he was
separated from the group and came face
to face with the Smith's vicious guard
Hound despite his youth Satanta defeated
the hound and then promised to act as
the Smith's new guard dog in recompense
thus cold Cullen or Cullen's Hound was
born again the next year kilcullen
overheard a prophecy spoken by his
maternal grandfather the Druid khatbot
it said that anyone who took up arms on
that day would have eternal Fame but
live a short life cocoon approached the
king that very day and asked to begin
his Warrior training thus sealing his
feet kukalan was sent to Scotland to
train with the renowned fighter skahak
who gifted him his legendary spear gay
bolga which could travel at lightning
speeds and shoot 30 little barbs from
its tip kukalin was naturally strong and
fast thanks to his Divine parentage but
while he was away he really learned the
the ways of both war and love he even
sired a son whom he later accidentally
killed by skahok's Daughter despite the
fact that he was betrothed to a woman
back in Ireland by the time he returned
to his homeland kukalan was a young man
often described as short and notably
beardless with fuzzy hair though it was
said that the women of Ulster were
driven mad with lust for him as perhaps
the most skilled of the king's Red
Branch Warriors it was kukalan's
responsibility to protect his land and
people whenever his strength speed and
training weren't enough to defeat a foe
kukalin relied on his special power
called the riastrad much like a Norse
Berserker kukalan could change form in
battle he grew to nine feet tall and one
of his eyes either bulged or rolled back
in his head and a haze of blood appeared
around his fuzzy Mane when kukullen was
in this state he was invincible and so
enraged he couldn't tell friend from foe
no one was safe from his ire and it was
nearly impossible to bring him back to
normal Upon returning home from a
particularly violent Mission kukalan
still gripped by the riastrad demanded
to be given an opponent to fight or else
he would kill everyone in the entire
Fortress instead of offering up a victim
the leaders of Ulster sent out a group
of naked women kukalan was so
embarrassed by the sight that he averted
his gaze giving the other Warriors time
to restrain him and dunk him in water
until he calmed down the people of
Ulster were grateful for Collins
murderous rage however when their
kingdom was invaded by the army of
Canucks Warrior Queen Maeve remember
when Moya told you cattle were valuable
in ancient Celtic societies well maeve's
master plan was to amass Empire Building
Wealth by stealing ulster's prize Bowl
on the day of the attack all of the
soldiers in ulster's Army were struck
down by a curse that gave them menstrual
pangs and prevented them from fighting
to that I say two things one this
wouldn't have happened if you had more
women warriors who already knew how to
fight through the pain and two it was
cool Cullen's time to shine and what
became known as the legendary tanbow
quelnia or the cattle raid of Coulee 17
year old Collins single-handedly fought
off maeve's Army one soldier at a time
for days until the rest of the Ulster
men recovered enough to back him up
maeve's Army was forced to retreat but
it wouldn't be their last invasion of
cook Collins Home in a classical tragedy
this would be about the time that Colin
would be lured from the path of
greatness by his fatal flaw he would
demonstrate too much hubris or get
caught up in a web of his own lies but
instead of a fatal flaw it's something
called a gesh that leads to kilcullen's
demise gesha are taboos or curses or can
even be seen as gifts bestowed upon
people by their parents a druid or some
other authority figure to break a gash
is to bring about extreme Misfortune
cocoon's Behavior was constrained by two
gesha he must accept any food offered to
him by a woman and he must not eat dog
meat if you are familiar with common
folklore tropes you might be able to see
where these unfortunately contradicting
taboos will lead our hero when kukon one
was 27 years old Queen Maeve and one of
his other enemies lugaid mercuroy
invaded Ulster on his way to the battle
kukalan was tricked into accepting Hound
meat from a group of women breaking one
Gish to uphold another
the strength and power were immediately
sapped from his body and he was made
vulnerable to weapons kukalin was
mortally wounded in that battle by one
of lugaid's Spears but he didn't go down
without a fight in one last heroic move
kukalan tied himself to a standing Stone
and faced down his opponents even in
death his reputation kept the other Army
at Bay for more than a day until a raven
landed on his body and broke the
illusion kakullen likely wasn't based on
a real person but the legendary figure
continues to inspire an influence in
modern day Ireland you can find murals
and statues dedicated to him around the
country and references to him can be
found in media around the world like the
popular myth-based video game Smite In
classical literature according to
Aristotle tragic Heroes were defined by
their fatal flaw in untimely death one
could argue that Colin fits this mold
and that his fatal flaws were the hubris
impulsivity and desire for fame that led
him to fulfill katbod's prophecy at the
age of seven but KU Collins death was a
too early at all he always knew his days
were numbered and he got exactly the
destiny he wanted he lived the Rough and
Tumble life of a warrior built a
reputation as a truly fearsome opponent
and continued to live on in national
memory for thousands of years sorry
Aristotle but that doesn't sound very
tragic to me